I love Peter and that like hasn't
changed since that day in Australia I
know the love and the respect I have for
you and that's never changed it's the
break-up no one saw coming
just kidding Peter Webber and Madison
Pruitt have officially called it quits
just two days after they told us all
they were going to give things a shot
during the bachelor finale I think that
you know I I know how we both feel about
each other and you know I think like you
know taking like one step at a time
well now we see how that worked out both
Peter and Maddy shared very lengthy post
to Instagram basically both thinking
each other for the love and journey they
each went through I'm excited that
there's a reason and no one's gonna find
out the ending and I'm excited about
that at least now we all know how this
story ended and no one is happier about
this news than Peter's mom barb who has
made her feelings for Mattie very
well-known she had us wait three hours
for her to come in to she didn't want to
meet us Chris he's gonna have to fail to
succeed that's it a mother's intuition
is never wrong
after the break-up barb posted this very
happy sing-along know when I'll be back
again now - even more tea et has learned
that Peter and Maddy were actually
hanging out hours before they announced
their split maybe they were planning out
their Instagram captions and eyewitness
spot of them at the restaurant
Grandville in Studio City on Thursday
and told ET quote it looked like a very
intense conversation Maddy seems to be
in good spirits though I mean how's this
for a breakup support group she was
hanging out with Selena Gomez on
Thursday night Maddie what ko do you
want
we're gonna have a great night in and if
you think it's a weird pairing it's
really not sourced ldt the pair met
through Hillsong Church and have a ton
of mutual friends as for Peter we think
he'll be just fine though Chris Harrison
did tell us he was having a hard time
after his finale
I have exchanged texts with Peter today
and all I will say cuz I don't want to
give too much away because it's a really
personal conversation he's having a
tough time he's a little beat up by
everything alright guys that's it for
today and for all the latest on bachelor
nation stick with all things beauty
until next time I'm Katie crafts and bye
for now
[Music]